if it is not possible to converge closer
people disperse further
life all the time distracts our tension
and we do not even have time to notice
from what exactly
[Music]
many a book is like a key to unknown
chambers within the castle
of one's own self
there are two cardinal sins from which
all others spring
impatience
and laziness
youth is happy because it has the
capacity to see beauty
anyone who keeps the ability to see
beauty
never grows old
[Music]
i write differently from what i speak
i speak differently
from what i think
i think differently
from the way i ought to think
and so it all proceeds into the deepest
darkness
a first sign
of the beginning of understanding
is the wish to die
the meaning of life
is that it stops
all language is but a poor translation
[Music]
books
are a narcotic
by believing passionately in something
that still does not exist
we create it
the non-existent
is whatever we have not sufficiently
desired
it is not difficult to love the ones who
leave
i think we ought to read only the kind
of books
that wound and stab us
[Music]
paths are made by walking
i have the true feeling of myself
only when i'm unbearably unhappy
he is terribly afraid of dying
because he hasn't yet lived
and men struggle against the world
bet on the world
first impressions
are always unreliable
anyone looking for evidence of
infidelity
hopes not to find it
from a certain point onward
there is no longer any turning back
that is the point that must be reached
just
think how many thoughts the blanket
smothers
while one lies alone in bed
and how many unhappy dreams
it keeps warm
everything
including lies
serves the truth
the book should be an ice pick
for the frozen sea within us
only people affected by the same ailment
understand each other
if a woman decides to cheat
she is in search of the best
and if a
man he just needs novelty
a person who lies in love
does not even deserve to be hated
nobody can give more
than the one who has lost everything
he who has cognized the fullness of life
does not know the fear of death
the fear of death
is only the result of an unfulfilled
life
pay no attention to anyone
do what you think is right
it is impossible to make excuses
when they do not want to believe you
thoughts that are spoken out loud
immediately and finally lose their
meaning
you